what's up believe nation welcome to
another YouTube interview super excited
to be here with a legend in the house a
true entrepreneurial marketing legend
this man has been the mentor to guys
like Tony Robbins Daymond John Stephen
Covey Brian Tracy he has been known
historically as the nine billion dollar
man for having generated over nine
billion dollars in revenue for the
clients has worked with I'm sure that
number is a lot higher now and if you've
ever heard of the term unique selling
proposition this is a guy who came up
with it and gave it a ton of exposure
the man the myth the legend Jay Abraham
welcome aboard thank you very much and
it's an honor to contribute now as
people are joining in as a live session
I want to show you something quickly
this is a binder that I have in the
green room Jay was asking if I was
familiar with his work and like yeah man
I'm feeling with the work when I started
my first company the real company I was
19 years old I'm what 38 almost now so
almost 20 years there were two resources
that I loved on the side here if you
guys can see it says unlimited power by
Tony Robbins right and then on the other
side it says Jay Abraham and notes all
that's in here are like pages and pages
and pages and and you were like my my
marketing professor because I didn't
have that in my in my family in my life
and so I I've kept that that's that's
almost that binder is 20 years old and
so I just want to thank you for all your
contributions you've done to help
entrepreneurs my journey to can we turn
it around for a moment you know me well
enough by my work that what what rocks
by boat is not acknowledgement it's
people who do things in the marketplace
and make a difference so everything I've
heard about your work is is designed to
move people to action so I thank you
because that's what it's all about I
love it I love it so we've got a whole
bunch of people joining a live guys as
you're watching if you have a question
for Jay put in the chat tag me it's
gonna be a lot easier to see but first
Jay you know I'm curious I'm curious
what your mission is I mean you've been
doing this for so long you've helped
best of the best you know you've made
tons of money and you're still going
strong you're still offering tons of
free resources to people what is it
that's driving you to keep doing what
you're doing well it's about for
integrated things Evan first of all the
driver in the beginning was my hopeless
curiosity and that turned out to be my
my strengths I basically traveled from
one industry to another and discovered
all kinds of different ways of thinking
that were not known in in other
industries and it was an extraordinary
discovery for me it was an epiphany and
now I've done about a thousand
industries and I keep learning and every
time I learn great honestly because of
the knowledge base that I possess it
gives me another level of exponential
growth and it's it's it's a high that
you can't quite explain to people but
it's it's very very powerful number one
number two is I believe an entrepreneur
is rewarded in life for the value and
the contribution they make to others and
I think there are far too many people
who dedicate a life to a business in
countless hours hopes dreams financial
expectations wealth creating asset
expectations and they unintentionally in
the unknowingly limit restrict constrain
all they can do not because they aren't
working in their mind their fullest out
but because they don't know how many
higher performing easier more profitable
more predictable less risky more
sustainable strategies business models
marketing approaches access models
competitive advantages alternative
revenue approaches exist and I have
since about you know molder than you
obviously since about your age I
realized that my purpose was to elevate
people to be preeminent preeminent means
your
is the only viable choice somebody could
make in your category your product or
service and they make that choice and
they see that because of what you
represent to them whether it's greater
benefit advantage support protection
enrichment whatever and they see and you
see that your organization your
rendering in the product the product
service itself your whole your whole
focus is on their betterment and I don't
that's too esoteric but then I love I've
been you know I've been very blessed to
travel the world and do it everywhere I
didn't trying to do Japan and I'm going
to be at Nam I'm going with Toni Toni
and I every year which gratifies me
enormously just because makes me
continue to be relevant Toni and I every
year do a full day together I think
without being arrogant I'm probably the
only person that does it and we do it
together which is hilarious back and
forth problem-solving to his is platinum
group I can go on and on but I I'm
driven I'm Purpose Driven more than
money driven got it I love it long
answer I apologize
now I like it I like it it's great to
get more context you know you've seen so
many entrepreneurs whether Suetonius
group or just people are hitting you up
what are some of the biggest challenges
that you see or some of the roadblocks
that you see in people's mindsets that
is preventing them from actually getting
to preeminence level with their goals
well okay can I break it into parallel
universes
let's go I love it so on the one hand
they are following the herd and they're
only thinking doing acting the way
everybody else does in their industry so
plus or minus 20 percent they're limited
if I they do are the same thing
everybody else does there's no way
they're going to have breakthroughs and
breakthroughs are not just financial
breakthrough is not just product service
breakthroughs but breakthroughs in the
way that they connect with their market
secondly the vast majority of them are
tactically minded they don't even
understand what strategy really looks
like third most entrepreneurs are
honestly two-dimensional they think in
terms of revenue less expense and that's
profit the really astute ones are
three-dimensional the third dimensional
is yield they didn't understand that
certain things have an enormous and
yield I started teaching 30 35 years ago
lifetime value LTV now is a bantered
around but thirty years ago nobody
understood that your if you play the
game correctly it has nothing whatsoever
to do with the first transaction it has
to do with the with the the aggregate
value of the of the ongoing purchases
that emanate from a buyer and also the
ancillary or utility revenue which could
be referrals which could be additional
complementary products or services most
people don't know I'm just going to go
through a a random litany here you can
stop me anytime most people don't
understand they allocate a budget or
their indiscriminate about marketing
they'll say oh five ten percent of sales
or they will say five ten thousand
dollars or a thousand dollars a month
you're either spending too much or too
little you have to realize that
different types kinds sources product
buyers are worth more or less and you
can't know what they're worth do you
analyze first of all the profit they
yield up front and then the residual
value that they that they turn into some
are worth five times what you're
investing and you have to look at it as
investment for a yield not not a cost
it's it's a renowned an expense it's a
cost of sales but it's an investment
there I learned evident please stop it
because I can go on a roll automatically
and if I don't look you in the eye I'm
not being disrespectful I'm accessing my
knowledge so everybody please don't
think be disrespectful to having them
try to be very respectful and just be
very sinuate
yeah I got very very fortunately
introduced to three different ideologies
concurrently one
was you I worked with people that wanted
to make things better I also worked with
people that wanted to fill gaps that did
not exist then I learned and this was
the definitive change that you can you
can work on the geometry of a business
and it was easier to grow a business
exponentially than it is incrementally I
also realized that revenue may be
important but you can multiply by orders
of magnitude the profit without having
to necessarily increase the revenue
accordingly and when I learned things
like the 3 way to grow a business model
the 9 drivers the the sticking point
solutions those happen to be 9 the 12
strategy pillars and then the strategist
rata G of preeminence and things like
that leverage marketing I realized there
were as many as 60 70 leverage points
within an existing revenue system that
could be improved each one of which 10
15 percent improvement sounds modest but
the cumulative effect is geometric it's
hundreds or thousands of percent
multipliers in the in the performance of
the business and if you go if you want
you don't have to but my background took
me to very far and and interesting
places I worked for example for the
Deming organization Deming was the man
who came to hear from he went to Japan
first because he was rejected here he
taught the Japanese carmakers and
electronics makers quality and process
improvement meaning making each process
10-15 percent better because it makes
the end the end result hundreds of
percent better and he got the Sony's and
the Toyota's to become really cool cool
viable sources but he taught he taught
optimization highest and best use theory
and most people can't optimal
it's because they don't have a context
of knowledge of how many better higher
performing less expensive less risky
more impactful more profitable more you
know more sustainable alternative means
of marketing or market access exists so
the first one is most people don't
optimize how they attract prospects and
and convert them both targeting
proposition secondly they don't set
people up for a sustainable purchase
like a perpetual or at least a
sustainable purchase process secondly
they don't try to ethically optimize the
size of the sale third they don't try to
optimize the frequency or the utility
fourth they don't realize that by adding
either an easier entry point or more
advanced and expensive what I'll call an
end product you can double or triple or
quadruple the profit of that business
fourth they don't realize that if they
don't have resources which a lot of them
don't they have an infinite capacity and
unlimited checkbook by figuring out who
already has access to the same market
they want to reach it is not competitive
in doing not affiliate deals but very
deep and strategically forged power
partnerships joint ventures fatigue
alliances we've done billions of dollars
just with that using other people's
resources and we've identified something
like forty three main ways they can do
it and about a hundred derivatives of it
one of the other things that's hilarious
Evan if you if you if you query your
canvas the majority of small
medium-sized businesses and you ask them
how many of you can say that twenty to a
hundred percent of your revenue comes
from referral or word-of-mouth a
surprisingly large number will raise
their hand but I'm doing sessions with
large groups I make them stand up and I
keep them standing up and then I go
around randomly and say well what's the
percentage and what's the dollars and
it's really quite amazing they'll say
eighty percent two million they'll say
forty percent
five hundred thousand you get some wild
ones a hundred percent eight million and
then I'll say well okay we remain
standing if your business has in place
right now at least one formalized
systematized continuously at a year to
buy every one referral generating
strategy that you use all the time and
ninety percent will sit down of the
remaining ten percent I'll say two
processes ninety percent will sit down
three they all sit down we've identified
in all these categories because I worked
for so many different businesses and
looked at so many different strategic
approaches marketing approaches tactical
as well as a strategy business access
approaches we found ninety three
separate referral generating strategies
that could be used now nobody's going to
use all ninety three but if you think
about it having a referral generated
buyer number well let me give you a
different example the people that get
mostly referrals waste a lot of money in
the outside market trying to get first
tier veneer trust then you have to work
their asses off to take that tentative
trust and convert it to buying trust
where as a referral generating buyer is
ready to buy he or she's predisposed
they negotiate less they buy quicker
they buy more things they buy more often
they're more enjoyable to deal with they
refer more people and they cost nothing
and I'm gonna stop dominating I can do
no it's great I mean it's guys watching
as you can tell Jay is a wealth of
information it's why in my binder I had
to take all these detailed notes you
know he skimmed over 25 different ideas
in that little rant there and and all of
them have a lot more layers of detail
that
you can go into I'm sure actually this
is a great resource on Jays website
right now is how I found a lot of this
stuff earlier on in my days called Fifty
Shades where he has over 800 hours of
free resources for you guys to check out
talking about a lot of those strategies
like what are some of the ninety three
ways to get referrals and it's all free
and there's no sale so we've linked up
his website in description you can go
check it out I want to get to some of
the questions the live chat so you guys
have a question tag me up and we can
have J answer them quickly
Zachary saying J how do you market your
personal brand better well there's a lot
of ways let's start where I started when
I started nobody knew me so I would go
to influencers and influencers is a
relative term depending on where you are
on the on the food chain influencers in
your community influences and your
category influencers big and I would
offer to work for them gratis and first
of all exchange my perspective with them
so that they could validate and if it
produced a meaningful not just a modest
a meaningful result all I wanted in
exchange was their aggressive
endorsement that I could use outside and
if they were willing and I never pushed
for it
their endorsement to their affinity
group and I had to work many many many
months at a second job while I was
building this but I had about a hundred
people at a time I was helping and I
scored on about 80 I'm not perfect and I
ended up getting great affinity and I
parlayed that up the food chain to where
at one time we had almost a hundred of
the top authors in the sector all
endorsing me and then we do some wild
things we sent out letters to target
audiences that had all of their
signatures together and we would call it
the declaration of success and it it
would say we never we rarely agree on
anything but we all agree that you get
you have to really get to know this man
as far as this jet
goes what I try to do when I started I
went up and down the corridors where I
live in Indianapolis which does have a
lot of entrepreneurs I made lists of
influential and at the time innovative
entrepreneurs and I would I would call
on them and and ask if I could interview
them and I became very good and we've
got something I think on that Abraham
comm fifty shades on Socratic
interviewing and critical thinking and I
was able to learn by asking better
questions and listening I mean I took I
usurped you in that last little splurt
which is probably disrespectful but I'm
known for being very frankly an
exquisite and deep and reflective
listener and if you listen and ask great
questions and try to understand someone
else's reality you know what you know
and you try to understand where they're
coming from how they're coming how they
got to where they are what they're
defining beliefs are even if they don't
know it three things happen you grow
like mad but secondly if you ask really
meaningful questions and you demonstrate
that you are listening and they really
believe that you're grasping it and they
start talking about themselves you get
bonded to them and they like you more
and Tony Robbins would say it's one of a
number of different denominations of NLP
but I spent hours and hours interviewing
people but not interviewing the way that
you would interview or I would interview
if it was a a podcast but just asking
them about how they got there asking
them about what their beliefs are asking
them about why they thought that their
their success was so distinctive asking
them about some of the adversity asking
them about the mindset that they used
when they had to transcend that and and
having that doubt if you have expertise
then you start
asking them questions they've never
asked themselves we have and I think
it's up on that same site 200 page
self-assessment and it's my boy it asks
questions no one's ever asked you and
your company you've never thought of it
shows your correlations implications
gaps and it's self-evident just by the
questions we ask that you don't even
know how to ask yourself that there is
there is exceptional understanding that
we possess and we is really mean but I
do have a company so I I include
everybody we have an 87 questions
self-assessment called how does your
business really stack out I believe the
best way to gain success is through
results it's not through rhetoric it's
not through great sales hyperbole it's
just to go out and and and particularly
if you're an expert with underutilized
time and at that time has denominator
both value let's say that you would
charge $200 an hour and you're only
doing a half a day on average now and
you have a half a day available which is
four times 200 you can buy somebody
eight hundred dollars of your time I do
not believe in giving anything free but
I do believe in contextualizing it or
semantics however you want to say it
buying someone 800 hours your time get
deep with people who have influence get
deep with people who you know have have
things to teach get deep with people
that'll allow you to get experience in
different industries or environments if
you can't get money also I always went
to organizations that had access to the
markets I want we did seminars which you
might have been introduced to when you
started I stopped 20 years ago but we
did a quarter-billion and I'm not saying
that to be arrogant we really did and I
did 99% of them by going
- pardon me - affinity groups
influencers associations magazines that
had access to the market I wanted which
were small medium entrepreneurs and
winning their trust their performance
and then getting them to feel
comfortable endorsing us to their lists
of their database but not just endorsing
us like an affiliate but creating
monster integrated collaborative
programs where we would do special
issues of a newsletter we would send out
back then record whether it be a
cassette or a CD where we would we would
actually send out pre pre commitment
short course primers that would make
them enough money before they ever had
to commit to pay for it for them a lot
of really cool things for the genre and
I'm gonna I don't mean to keep getting
out of I'm looking at you can't tell if
you're if you're bedazzled if you're
angry if you're shocked or if I'm taking
your thunder that's all good this is
your you're the you're the guest here
you tell your thunder one of the things
I want to really highlight and why I
love your material was you don't just
get the strategies you would also give
the the script it's like here take this
script when you're calling them say this
or in an email write this and swap out a
couple things but instead of just
staying really high level you would also
take it massively tangible on every
single level so for someone who wants to
outreach to influencer or wants to get
on those people's radars like what's the
first step what is the email that you
say and or what's the phone call that
you make like take me tactical into
making that first introduction okay and
and you're asking one of the things that
I drive people crazy with is that I
don't believe in one-size-fits-all
so you've ever seen a woman in a
one-size-fits-all address one of them
looks stunning and the rest either it's
too tight to lose too short too long so
I'll give you some specifics okay
pardon me depending if you possess
unique expertise and the first thing I
try to do is help people who are expert
be able to quantify contrast compare in
other words if you have a skill set can
you to nominate what that skill set can
mean to me in either higher production
cost saving more clients buyers annual
revenue any denomination that makes my
intangible analogize to tangible once I
can do that and I don't like people who
over estimate i think conservativism is
very important because you'll never
you'll never disappoint yourself or the
other side you'll always if you're
really good over deliver but I would
basically say one approach is to say
that I possess an expertise there are
other people out there certainly and I
know many of them and this is what we
always do to try to that we call it
dividing and conquering - when I work
with an expert there I know most of them
there for the most part they're quality
men and women good husbands and fathers
they do good work but their approach to
what I do is so different than mine I
play a much more elevated game of and
then you fill in the blank
quantification result based delivery
looking at you know at impact whatever
it is then you can say I would like to
buy you or your you know if there's a
expert or a decision maker under the
head of the business I'd like to buy
your you know your plant manager or your
operations manager your HR department
two hours of my time during which I will
share both my unique methodology
dietary methodology but I will also
transfer ways of thinking and doing that
I promise we'll have encounter capable
value whether we ever do business or not
I have found that investing in quality
relationships always comes back it'll
mean a lot to me to have the chance to
contribute but I think it'll mean a lot
more to your to your whatever it is
that's one approach another approach is
that I am an expert in this field but in
all honesty I see that you and your
business have taken the category to you
know to a strata beyond almost anybody
I've studied I would be very pleased to
interview and get your thinking and and
learn your your perspectives to add to
what I do because I'm always trying to
improve my own ability by by learning
from people who take it whatever the
skill set is to you know to a much
higher level another way is is the truth
I have enormous expertise I have been
able to utilize it in smaller
environments I believe with all my heart
and soul that it has the capacity to
impact companies of your size and type
even more and I need you know I need
some guinea pigs
I would love to offer to buy you my
services after I've convinced you of its
viability and suitability and and
potentiality but first I would like to
to get on the phone with you or Skype or
if you'd allow me to fly and meet you to
share with you how differently I think
and how uniquely I approach the subject
so you will feel comforted in giving me
the opportunity to systematically prove
it within your company as a as a
protection of you
I am very fine establishing progressive
application trenches and if I don't
achieve what I promised at that point
you can stop if I do achieve it we
continue I'm asking no compensation I'm
asking only collaboration if I achieve
the goal or over achieve it I would hope
you would give me a outrageous
endorsement testimonial it orjust me to
other people who are not competitive
like it also do it for and perhaps hmm
allow me to expand my work and be active
do you want to on a compensated today
range
things like that yeah it's great I hope
anybody who's actually trying to do that
pauses you know rewinds listen to that a
couple times
take word-for-word notes and actually
apply it Jane over a couple minutes over
thank you so much to your time
last question Jay Abraham in one word
most important core value what would it
be it would be making okay getting
people to respect everyone's relevancy
and falling in love with humanity and
humility and always realizing that your
responsibility is to make people better
off every time you're in their life in
as many ways as possible both in
business and personally if you do that
you're better your business is better
you prosper the world's better and you
operate at a more animated and liberated
place in life than you will ever imagine
it's intoxicating and wonderful that's
it intoxicating I like it
Jay thank you so much guys thank you so
much for watching there's been a ton of
questions like that came up that we
didn't get to but go check out abraham
calm over 800 hours of material is 50
shades i what is the 58
2/5 of shades that's where everything
resides thank you to get other stuff
there but it's a special page for
contribution perfect well thank you Jay
for the time thank you for great making
those great resources available online -
thank you everybody for watching have an
amazing rest of your Thursday and we'll
see you soon thank you very much